من يصدق ان هؤلاء البؤساء يعيشون كاقيه
على ارض لهم شاسعه وغنيه ناضلوا من اجلها
[موسيقى]
طويلا
ز
[موسيقى]
ا
kend bir alel olan ve ktel geli en baan
beri yaz belgeler takip eden uygur eski
ardan beri huki belgeler kyor ve dzen
bir devlet ariv sahler
uygur ileri dere gmi gmi en es med tk
[موسيقى]
to
ا
[موسيقى]
رحمت ب جان ا اان قران ا اان
قران
[موسيقى]
لكن دولتهم الحلم لم تعمر اكثر من خمس
سنوات عندما سقطت على يد الصين الشيوعيه
بعد موت افراد حكومتهم في حادث طائره غامض
كانت تقلهم للاجتماع بالزعيم الصيني
الراحل ماوتسي
[موسيقى]
دون
انا كون الاويغور اطلب من كل العالم
العربي والاسلامي الا يتركنا لوحدنا وان
يقف معنا امام الظالمين واكبر المجرمين
واطلب من المشايخ ان يخبر الشعوب
بقضيتنا